so what is like the process of making a
cosplay because my all of my experience
and knowledge comes from watching
dress-up darling and that and that's it
and i like know nothing about what goes
on behind the scene basically in terms
of making a costume
no that's fair um although actually yeah
it had a lot of like stuff that was uh
pretty accurate yeah like um the
research phase and stuff like that
getting a guy that will do it for you
getting a boredom
make this for me no um doing a lot of
like the
the planning process or honestly before
that finding something that you're in
love with okay because i feel like 90 of
the time when you're like in that
cosplay crunch and you want to like
throw everything out and you're like
this is [ __ ] balls i hate this [ __ ]
your love of the character drags you
through the glass you know and you go
like oh i [ __ ] love this i don't
[ __ ] care like i i need like no no
sleep you know i'm gonna do this how
much time do you normally put into a
costume it can depend it really depends
i have like a a mental timer it's about
one to two weeks
where if i like if i'm gone beyond that
i will forget about it i made a
gentleman cho'gath and it took longer
than two weeks and they disappeared and
i don't know what it is someone choke it
yeah
because she disappeared
because i i didn't finish it because i
had the i had the stiletto feet and
everything sounds so good i had the
[ __ ]
monster from league of legends yeah it's
like [ __ ] ugly oh that's why you're
so great that's why i don't need
that's why he's happy that's why i'm
happy that's why he doesn't need therapy
okay exactly
yes
i did i did okay i did it's true and
then i got started
and i've been league-free
so one to two week timer of like how
long i can work on something just
because i personally don't want to put
that much like energy into something and
you know because like there is a time
where you can become too hyper focused
on something and it can like make you go
a little nuts because then you're like
you're ultra focused on all the
different details and you're just kind
of like
what so you got to let it go you know
let it go you got to send it out into
the universe right yeah so it's usually
about that and then you like the
creation process is like i've seen you
post like you did the iron mouse one
recently and you were like you were like
by the way yeah that was awesome yeah
and you did it usually like it's a quick
cosplay it was a speed run what does
that mean how fast like uh like like
four or five days i would uh ryan's back
in here but i would like wake up iron
mouth sleep wake up i didn't sleep you
know like
ball ball ball
it was like i think i was watching like
xqc gamble or something
i was just like
the whole time you weren't even watching
mouse
during that period so i didn't want to
like i didn't want to i did watch mouse
but like i didn't want to like like do
that in case it would like i don't know
i don't distract you from yeah because
her stuff is so cute and so she makes i
don't know i love her as a content
creator she inspires the ever loving
[ __ ] out of me yeah her her attitude
about everything and just like the way
that she tackles everything going on i'm
just like
you're [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah she is
a great thing shout out to han mouse
i am going to send it to her too
so what do you say she said that yeah
yeah so when you said one to two weeks
it is one to two weeks full-on every day
you wake up you do costume you sleep oh
my god
i mean i guess that's become your job at
this point right yeah but it's it's like
a it's like giving birth and then uh
i need you to finish that sentence right
now you bring a baby into this
yeah it's like taking a big poop and
then you do it and then and then you
want to like take a break
yeah yeah
and then i then i usually like go you
got to raise it up you know you know but
i assume like you know taking pictures
and doing all that stuff also takes a
long time yes yeah so ryan will actually
take my photos and then we'll send it
off to someone to edit either martin or
our friend robbie and like that's that's
really i'm so lucky that ryan is able to
take my photos too because it's like a
comfortability thing as well so if i'm
like crying and take a photo of my
[ __ ] he's like a baby
spread it
oh my god
is that a normal topic absolutely